ich zeige Ihnen einmal was das aktuell
für die Stimmung in Deutschland bedeutet
wir haben zum Wochenende einmal mit
Hilfe des Meinungsforschungsinstituts
Insa gefragt wie es um das Vertrauen in
die
krisenbewältigungskompetenz der
Bundesregierung aktuell steht und da
sagen eben weit über 60% aktuell der
deutschen na da habe ich wenig Vertrauen
rein dass diese Regierung meine
Alltagsprobleme löst 30% sagen im Moment
noch da gibt es ein großes Vertrauen
über 64% eben geringes Vertrauen und
noch krasser wird es wenn wir auf die
einzelnen Minister gucken wir haben
einzeln abgefragt die topminister der
Bundesregierung ist das aus ihrer Sicht
die richtige oder die falsche Besetzung
für dieses Amt und da gewinnt keiner
dieser abgefragten Personen in grünen
Balken sondern schon beim Kanzler sagt
die Mehrheit das ist eine Fehlbesetzung
bei Christian Lindner dem Frieden dem
Finanzminister sagt die Mehrheit ist
eine Fehlbesetzung und besonders heftig
ist die sind die Zahlen für Robert
Habeck und für die Ver Bundesministerin
also Robert Habeck mittlerweile auch die
überwiegende Zahl der deutschen die
sagen das ist eine Fehlbesetzung Herr
Steinhöfel sie haben Teil dieser
Regierungs sozusagen mit ihrer Stimme
mitgewählt sie haben das darf ich sagen
haben sie gesagt FDP gewählt sind sie
enttäuscht von ihm naja das ist bei der
FDP ja eine ewige Geschichte von ihm bin
ich nicht enttäuscht weil die von ihm
nichts erwartet habe das meine ich jetzt
gar nicht so böse aber ich habe ja von
ihnen sie sind Fraktionsvorsitzender der
sie regieren nicht so
ja genau so dass sie bereits
ich habe Erwartung von denen die in der
Regierung sind so war das gemeint
das habe ich Ihre Frage vergessen ob sie
enttäuscht sind als FDP Wähler von dem
was geboten wird an fdp-politik wenn wir
uns wenn wir uns die die Zahlen da
gerade anschauen die wir gesehen haben
muss man natürlich einsehen dass das
Zahlen sind die jetzt so in einem das
ist im Moment Aufnahme sagen Politiker
wenn sie schlechte Zahlen haben sagen
Sie im Moment Aufnahme die durch den
Krieg natürlich extremen bestimmte
Richtungen geschoben werden aber
ich finde es gut dass die andere regiert
weil ich es als unabdingbar erachtete
das Merkel und alles was für Merkel
steht von der CDU in die Opposition geht
denn diese Partei ist völlig verbraucht
sie hat regiert und regiert und regiert
und alle die
Positionen eingenommen haben die nicht
der Position von Frau Merkel entsprochen
haben die hatten praktisch keine Stimme
mehr in der Union jetzt haben wir mit
März gehofft das ändert sich es ändert
sich nichts er hat sich bei wüst und bei
Günther die beide schwarz grüne Tendenz
ganz klar dokumentieren untergehakt und
er ist doch derjenige der sich jetzt an
der Tendenz in der Partei unterwirft die
dafür wesentlichen mitverantwortlich ist
mit der SPD von Herr Stegner für den
Zustand in dem wir uns aktuell befinden
da wähle ich doch nicht diejenigen die
den Mist angerichtet haben um den Mist
den andere zur Hälfte jedenfalls nicht
zu verantworten haben wegzuräumen es
gibt also keine Alternative außen rechts
und links gibt's auch keine Alternative
wobei sie sich wirklich mal fragen
müssen wie kann das angehen dass eine
Partei in einem derart cut auch so
freien Zustand wie die AFD im
Ostdeutschland stärkste Partei ist das
sagt doch alles raus über das was die
Menschen die Menschen denken über die
Kompetenz derer die zur Lösung berufen
sind selbst bei ihnen im eigenen Lager
in der FDP regt sich mittlerweile
Widerstand einzelne Ortsverbände sagen
lieber lieber nicht regieren als
schlecht regieren hätte also einzelne
Ortsverbände haben immer auch
richtigerweise Kritik an der eigenen
Regierungspartei und das gehört zu einer
Demokratie dazu also ich bitte Sie das
wäre absurd wenn das nicht so wäre dann
würden dann würde ich mir das ist in
jeder Pleite Herr Stegner alle wir
könnten Herr März auch einladen die
würden alle ein Lied davon singen das
doch vollkommen in Ordnung das gehört zu
in der parteilichen Demokratie dazu die
Frage ist doch wie löst man Probleme das
ist doch jetzt eigentlich die Frage um
diesen Druck in der in der Regierung ist
und wie viele da selbst schon bei vielen
davon wirklich politische Analysen oder
waren sie wollen die Menschen die Leute
wollen schon wissen ob das stabil ist
was sie da gerade bieten oder ob das
daran einziges Getränke und darauf
wollte ich gerade hinaus ich hätte mir
gewünscht dass wir für die zentralen
Probleme die Deutschland auch vor dem
September letzten Jahres vor der
Bundestagswahl hatte dass wir das vier
Jahre lang machen können Energie hätten
wir eh ran gewusst haben wir im
Koalitionsvertrag einiges vereinbart ich
mach mal einen anderen Punkt
Einwanderung die Union hat über 30 Jahre
lang behauptet Deutschland sei kein
Einwanderung wir hatten Einwanderung in
die sozialen Sicherungssystem aber nicht
in Arbeitsmarkt das Drehen wir in der
Ampel gerade um an der Stelle da komme
Thema planungsbeschleunigung an der
Stelle ist mir wesentlich schneller
werden jetzt stellen wir einsfest wie
unter einem Brennglas dieser Krise das
muss sofort passieren deswegen haben wir
gerade eine Reihe von Gesetzesform
natürlich würde ich mir wünschen dass
morgen gleich Deutschland reformiert ist
was für den letzten 16 Jahren falsch
gelaufen ist aber wir arbeiten daran
meistens der Probleme die Sie aktuell zu
tun haben keine trotzdem keine Frage ob
sie permanent überhaupt noch wissen
wohin dieses Boot dieses regierungsboot
gerade steuert Einzelteile der FDP wie
gesagt sagen das funktioniert nicht mehr
mit dem Habeck Laster raus haben sie mal
mit dem Verband in Stralsund gesprochen
wir haben Kontakt natürlich auch zu
denen die Robert Habeck kritisieren und
ganz offen ein bisschen der Kritik habe
ich vorhin auch geäußert weil ich ist
mir wünschen würde dass er schneller ist
an der ein oder anderen Stelle ist auch
gar keine Frage
aus dem FDP Ortsverband in Stralsund ist
bei uns und kann uns einmal erklären
kann Herrn Dörr einmal erklären hier bei
Bild die richtigen Fragen warum sie das
nicht mehr mehr länger mittragen wollen
mit der Ampel airbuschen also warum soll
Herr Dörr jetzt nach noch nicht mal im
Jahr sagen das war's schaffen wir nicht
mehr dann habe ich Geburtstag ja guten
Abend erstmal vielen Dank dass ich hier
sein darf und schöne Grüße aus Stralsund
ich möchte erstmal noch auf Herrn
Stegner eingehen
gute Talkshow Logik aber das machen wir
nicht die Frage war ganz klar und ihr
sitzt der also ganz klar warum wollen
sie raus aus der Ampel
was ich sehe ist die FDP kann sich in
dieser rot-grünen Regierung nicht
durchsetzen bedauerlicherweise das muss
man so halt sagen
wir hatten einen sehr klaren Slogan aus
Liebe zu Freiheit
und dazu sollten wir auch stehen
und unser Hauptproblem gerade ist doch
jetzt wir haben nicht nur die
radikalsten freiheitseinschränkungen der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland ertragen müssen jetzt in
dieser Regierung das war noch radikaler
als alles was die große Koalition in der
corona-zeit beschlossen hat nein jetzt
müssen wir auch noch sehen wie die Ampel
70 Jahre lang
erarbeiteten Wohlstand vernichtet
innerhalb von nur zehn Monaten also wir
stehen gerade wir reden über
Blackouts wir reden darüber dass die
Industrie komplett kollabiert dass wir
eine Gaskrise haben der Mittelstand der
Bericht zusammen was wir hier da sehen
bei der Demo das waren Bürger für
Stralsund das waren CDU oder das waren
fdp-ler das waren sehr sehr viele
Unternehmer das waren Hoteliers das war
ein Restaurantbesitzer das war die die
HOGA die dort vertreten war das war auch
ein Bürgermeisterkandidat von der Linken
und der Bürgermeister Oberbürgermeister
aus Stralsund hat das als Privatperson
auch unterstützt
ist ein offener Brief geschrieben der
jetzt in die Konsequenz aus all dem was
Sie gesagt haben ziehen will und er sagt
das hat hier keinen Sinn mehr ich glaube
es ist vor kurzem hätten sie all das was
Herr Buschner gerade gesagt hat komplett
unterschrieben da wäre das ihr Text
gewesen sein damals nie gab es mehr zu
tun und das wird ja mehr als deutlich
nie gab es mehr zu tun als jetzt und
natürlich kann man als Partei sagen ich
will lieber keine Verantwortung aber in
so einer Krise zu sagen ich will keine
nein ich bin in die Politik gegangen um
was zu verändern und Verantwortung zu
übernehmen und ich will die beiden
Beispiele die Herr burschener sagte das
gehört zu in der Partei ich Demokratie
vollkommen legitimer corona-politik
unterschiedlicher Mann beim Thema
corona-politik wenn ich mir angucke dass
wir lockdowns hatten Schulschließung und
sonst was das gibt's alles nicht mehr
das hättest doch nicht gegeben wenn mit
Verlaub Herr Stegner die große Koalition
regieren würde sondern das hat mit die
FDP erreicht in dieser Koalition und
beim Thema Wirtschaftspolitik und
Steuerpolitik beispielsweise am Anfang
der koalitionspfannung ich habe den Teil
selbst verhandelt mit den Kollegen von
SPD und Grünen gab es null Möglichkeiten
auf der entlastungsseite jetzt gehen wir
durch den Deutschen Bundestag und machen
eine echte Steuerentlastung für 48
Millionen Steuerzahlern Steuerzahler das
macht schon Unterschied gerne würde ich
mich zu 100% bei einem durchsetzen bei
den Fragen gerade Laufzeitverlängerung
Energie wollen wir mal schauen aber man
kann auch am Ende des Tages nicht
erwarten dass man 100 Prozent im wo ist
bei ihm aber gutes Punkt
wie viel Arbeitslose wie lange muss er
Habeck noch mit den Atomkraftwerken
warten wie tief muss sie corona-politik
von der Lauterbach gehen also wo ist der
schmerzlicherweise denn eine Sekunde den
Eindruck dass es Deutschland besser
gehen würde wenn sich jetzt eine
Regierung ernsthaft in so einer Krise
auslöst glauben Sie das kerke die
Kernkraftwerke würden verlängert in der
Laufzeit es würde gar nichts passieren
in Deutschland und das kann man
verantwortlicherweise nicht wollen
erstens und zweitens ich sage es nochmal
das interessantes verspricht genau das
der muss ja widersprechen
muss man sich zusammenraufen
da sagen die einen wir haben die
Mindestlohn eingeführt haben wir gemacht
wir haben ein Programm des
gesellschaftlichen Erneuerung wir werden
die Industriegesellschaft umbauen müssen
das werden wir zusammen besser können
als andere die das jetzt kritisieren
aber ist natürlich dürfen die Leute das
kritisieren natürlich haben die Angst
wenn Sie die Preise gibt unter anderem
die haben Angst da kriegt sich ausweitet
und das sind alles Themen mit dem was
man sich beschäftigen Kritik muss man
aushalten können aber am Ende ich sag's
ihnen noch mal wird die Regierung sich
als handlungsfähiger weisen wir werden
Vorschläge machen wir machen
gar nichts zu tun gar nichts zufällig
hat auch was damit zu tun Entschuldigung
wir haben momentan eine Aufgabe zu lösen
mitten in Europa wo die meisten Menschen
mir auf der Straße sagen Gott sei Dank
macht das der Olaf Scholz bei euch und
nicht der Herr Söder oder der märz oder
sonst irgendeiner von denen also es ist
auch ein Teil also
in der Schmerzpunkt wir vertiefen das
gleich wieder auch mit ihnen weil ich
deine Flotte aber wo ist der
Schmerzpunkt Herr Buschner hat den schon
erreicht hätte der Schmerzpunkt wäre
dann wenn ich ansatzweise das Gefühl
hatte dass die Opposition mit Verlaub
Dietmar Bartsch oder Friedrich Merz
bessere Vorschläge hätten ich kann das
nicht erkennen das mag bieten
anhand der Union mal deutlich machen was
ist denn zur Zeit die Politik was liegt
denn die Union vor Herr Stegner sagt es
vor die Union hat vorgeschlagen also
Friedrich Merz in Person dass wir seit
März keine Gaslieferung das wäre
verrückt gewesen machen uns nichts vor
das wäre die Politik in Deutschland
gewesen würde Friedrich Merz regieren
werden jetzt massive wirtschaftliche
Schäden aber zwei erweise das darf ich
ausführen an der Stelle was mich gefragt
haben Herr Merz und seine Partei schlägt
jetzt vor wir müssen Nachfrage Politik
machen und die Nachfrage anheizen über
Abwrackprämien von Haushaltsgeräten
jeder Ökonom schlägt die Hände über dem
Kopf zusammen ich bin nur die
blumenökonom aber ein bisschen was
kennen danke schön Herr Stegner mit
Verlaub also ich habe nicht den Eindruck
dass dort bessere Vorschläge kommen
trotzdem sehe ich uns in der Pflicht
ordentlich zu regieren gar keine Frage
da werden wir jetzt auch besser
hoffentlich in den kommenden Wochen den
wir konkrete energieentscheidungen
treffen aber da ist ja nicht ansatzweise
echter alternative erkennbar
denke ich es läuft alles in ihre
Richtung eigentlich der sagt genau ihren
Text aber irgendwie schlägt sich noch
nie hier oder nein das habe ich jetzt
beim anders gehört
wenn man sich halt das Endergebnis
anguckt dann haben wir gerade einen
Wirtschaftsminister der den kleinen und
mittelständischen Unternehmen sagt ihr
macht mal bitte sechs Monate nichts ich
meine laufende Kosten oder sowas gibt's
halt nicht kenne ich nicht verstehe ich
nicht gar nicht zur eigenen Leben also
dass das ist gerade die Regierungslinie
und so was man sich die Leute nicht
anhören und es gibt da halt schon klare
Forderungen die etwa auch auf dieser
Demonstration genannt wurden das ist
neben dem Rücktritt der Regierung etwa
die Öffnung von Nord Stream 2 was ja
unter anderem auch Kubicki vorgeschlagen
hat die Aufhebung der Sanktionen Frieden
durch plomatie etwa man könnte auch
sagen Frieden schaffen ohne Waffen was
ja ein kleines Wunder die Diskussion
läuft aber natürlich tatsächlich auf der
Straße
war Hella von denen hier zu Gast und hat
genau das gesagt und hat auch gesagt
also ihn würden Neuwahlen jetzt nicht
mehr wundern wie sehen Sie das
ich glaube keine Sekunde an Neuwahlen
weil das ist nun mal so naja die Ampel
ist ein Jahr im Amt die werden ja
irgendwie behämmert fragen Sie mal die
Abgeordneten sie müssten ja eine
Mehrheit dafür kriegen das schließlich
aus also so chaotisch ist die Lage nicht
es gibt ganz viele Probleme ich finde
die machen riesige Fehler ich glaube
keine Sekunde an Neuwahlen aber nur was
macht er halt da muss man Argument das
ist politisch ist das ich meinte das ist
natürlich
eine andere Frage ich er war erwarte ich
ich erwarte von der Regierung dass sie
die Probleme löst das ist die Aufgabe
und da sage ich es seit Monaten viel zu
wenig passiert denn die Beschreibung
stimmt doch einfach nicht nur was die
Gas und Strompreise betrifft sondern
auch was Nahrungsmittel was Inflation
all diese Punkte und da das eine
Überzeugung sehen die Menschen
Wirtschaftsminister ist hier mehrfach
genannt worden wenn ich mir allein die
ganzen Wolken anschaue seit Februar jede
Woche was anderes und da ist die benote
sehr gut aber die Anode die Substanz ist
verdammten und dann würde ich gerne mal
über die Dinge die vor Tische gesagt
sinnvolles Jahr es sind drei Parteien
natürlich ist es so dass man da sich
nicht eins zu eins durchsetzt was der
junge Kollege aus meiner Geburt statt
Stralsund sagt ist ja alles ganz
interessant aber die FDP hat erstens
nicht die absolute Mehrheit und wenn Sie
die absolute Mehrheit hätte wäre es fürs
Land auch nicht gut also das würde ich
jetzt anders
sagen ich erwarte dass diese Dinge die
angekündigt ist es so viel angekündigt
angeht dass sie angekündigt gemacht
werden
Punkt muss ich mal sagen wir reden über
die entlastungspakete 3 an der Zahl und
der wird von 95 Milliarden ich will die
Teile ist gar nicht überprüfen die
stimmt nicht aber ist egal aber über
Nacht wurden 100 Milliarden für den
sonderetat Bundeswehr das ging über
Nacht das wusste nicht immer die
Fraktion die waren alle erstaunt als
Olaf Scholz das sagte ich sehe dass der
Kanzler durch die Gegend fährt und dann
feiert das ein Schiff mit LNG kommt im
Dezember das ist eine alberne
Veranstaltung
ein bisschen also
sie sind weiter dran ich will nur ein
Haken sie haben gerade gesagt
dass das was die Bürger denken ja das
eine ist die haben macht er halt und das
ist ja ein wesentliches Argument dann
habe ich noch mal nachgefragt aber sagen
na ja das Vertrauen ist ja weg der
Menschen haben sie gesagt das ist ja
eine andere Frage nein entschuldigung
aber entschuldigen sie bitte ich ich
muss leider feststellen vor einem Jahr
ist genau ein Jahr her ist die
Ampelkoalition gewählt worden ich hätte
mir was anderes gewünscht ich habe
damals gesagt linke oder Lindner ich
glaube das stimmt im übrigen heute noch
es wäre eine ganz andere Politik aber
das muss ich zur Kenntnis nehmen und
immer wenn eine Regierung was falsches
macht kann ich nicht sagen Neuwahl wenn
dann wählen wir nach 14 Tagen neu
vertrauen wir haben das ja gerade
gesehen das ist schon spektakulär
Vertrauen genau
und sie haben vermutlich sogar recht
damit es ist völlig egal es ist völlig
egal ob das Vertrauen das ist völlig
egal wie gut die beiden Arbeiten die
machen halt einfach weiter
[Musik]